Travis luke says,
why are dragons in western culture bring
yourself death and destruction that
must be slain while in the east?
They're portant of good
fortune to be revered?
Well,
that's a great question,
by the way.
Um,
the,
the Dragon,
I already defined the
dragon at some point,
partly from a book I read a while
back on dragons as a tree cat,
snake bird.
The idea in the book was that the Dragon
was a imagistic representation of the
class of all predators,
which means also might be why dragons.
Um,
also breathe fire because
fire was undoubtedly a common
destructive agent in our
evolutionary past.
But the dragon is the most primordial
cysts symbol of that which looks beyond,
which is known.
In fact,
it's even more primordial than that
because it even is that which lurks beyond
what is unknown in some sense.
Remember Don Rumsfeld,
unknown,
unknown unknowns.
Well,
that's basically the drag.
There's some unknowns that pop up that
you can master right away and you can
kind of think of those as known unknown's.
But unknown unknowns are those things
that pop up that you don't know about.
You didn't even,
you had no idea whatsoever
that they even existed anyways.
What's the character of an unknown?
Unknown?
Well,
part of it's terrifying because it can,
it can,
it can do you in,
right,
but part of it's also
positive and and because it,
anything that's truly
unknown brings it with it.
A tremendous amount of new possibility.
That's why dragons hoard gold or why
they also heard princesses or guard
princesses hoard,
I would say is the right word.
So I don't think the dragon in the West
is a fully negative symbol because the
dragon has gold associated
with it or virgin.
The reason for that is that the hero
who confronts the Dragon gets the Virgin
and that hasn't changed.
That's,
that's a story as old as time and I
don't think it'll ever change as long as
there are human beings now why the Chinese
put stress on the positive side and
the West put stress on the
negative side is difficult to say.
I might say because the
Chinese got organized so early,
I have a sneaking suspicion that
it was easier for them to see.
A little bit of chaos
is something positive,
something necessary and positive as
a counterbalance to the tremendous
organizational weight of their state.
Um,
that's the best,
best answer that I've
been able to formulate.
Um,
so,
so anyways,
the dragon is a very complex
and ambivalence symbol.
It,
it combines everything into one symbol,
positive and negative,
and then you can stress the positive
or you can stress the negative.
You could also say to some degree that
whether a dragon is positive or negative
depends to some degree on the
manner in which you approach it.
Because the psychological reality is
that dragons approached voluntarily,
well,
small are most likely to be positive.
And that's a really good
thing to know in your life.
Uh,
it's a good reason.
It's a good rule of thumb to help you
stop avoiding things that you shouldn't
avoid so that they don't
grow and magnified beyond
your capacity to deal with
them.